what are you driving these days
a lamborghini are you making good money
from this business
i want to change the entire industry for
me this is this has got political it
started off as i wanted to build a big
business then you realize the hatred and
the pushback you get from these estate
agents and you realize the reason
there's so much hatred and pushback
is because you get you're exposing them
taiwan thanks for coming down to my
house brother killing it in property
you've built a massive name for yourself
over the last year or so channel 4 show
real estate agent conquering the real
estate market um i'm a big fan i love
what you guys are about i love what you
do why don't you just give an
introduction as to what is exactly that
your business does because it's unique
thank you for the kind intro to be
honest it was something that i kind of
i guess stumbled into because of lack of
options so i've been an estate agent
since i was probably about 18 years old
and i worked in kind of corporate high
street agencies i worked pretty much
right the way through
until i got to working at a luxury
property firm
was doing really well as a luxury agent
and i managed to negotiate like a
self-employed term with them um that was
all going very very well until i wanted
to expand so i was very social media
driven the uk has only just started
cottoning onto social media and
marketing yourself through social media
for property and property sales and i
was probably the first well i know i was
the first person ever to do a property
video tour in the uk
by probably about a year and a half
and
the reality was that um as i started
kind of pioneering that my social media
was growing people wanted to use me as a
luxury agent to sell all over the uk and
all over different parts of london
the company that i worked for at the
time they were a franchise brand where
you had to operate within a certain post
code bit like most estate agencies that
didn't work for me so then i started
going around to different real estate
companies to try and accommodate that no
one could accommodate it so i thought
well the only way i'm going to get this
done is if i do it myself so i that's
where the idea spawned for tyre national
real estate yeah we launched at the end
of very very end of 2019 so really going
into 2020 and so we're a pretty new
business just over two years two and a
half years old um
and yeah and here i am one of the things
you've got going for you i think though
is your marketing you guys are
aggressive marketers also it's
interesting that you put your face on it
like the name of the company tyrone ash
you're the face you're the brand and
you're selling multi-million pound
houses last
last year i know not only did you sell
millions of pounds worth of houses you
made millions of pounds in profit doing
it which is crazy i mean
what's your business model then so
you're charging the the the like a
traditional estate agent you're charging
the seller yes a fee yes and what do you
typically charge two and a half percent
two and a half is that like fixed yes
and and and how do you get people what
do people think do people think i don't
want you to sell my house because you're
gonna put it all over social media and
it's or do people like that or what yeah
i think there's been a bit of a
preconceived
um misconception that
the higher value properties need to be
these kind of under the table off market
yeah privacy privacy products that's how
it is though
and the reality is is that in order to
get your house sold especially your
luxury property you're not marketing so
maybe your buyer is localized maybe but
the reality is is that you know if you
are a luxury buyer you could be anywhere
yeah so you know we've had people from
london who've bought a property in
orderly edge we've had people from
canada buy a property in london bridge
yeah it does we don't know where that
luxury buyer is coming from so the way
that we attack that because we've got
the biggest following on social media
we're getting the most engagement from
an estate agency or real estate
perspective um so when we're marketing
stuff the engagement levels it's all
right an estate agent doing a video if
he's getting 50 views on the video then
what the [ __ ] the point and i do
mostly yeah they do i mean you know they
think oh you know it's a waste of time
my
my concept isn't the video itself it's
about what we do with that video so
we have probably around 10 pieces of
content
per listing
that's why i know we're so far ahead of
the game because they think oh we're
doing property videos
we're stratosphere the stratosphere is
ahead of that already yeah um so we need
to make sure that we've got
trailers coming soon videos walkthrough
tours and tick tock detailed video tours
and we're gaining these marketing
growing these marketing campaigns for
each property that's growing an audience
of tens of thousands of views per video
driving and funny is that why your
buyers are coming from there are your
buyers coming from instagram tick tock
social media yeah i mean the crazy thing
is like we've done the largest marketing
campaigns um on every single property
portal right through the website a door
knocking campaign letter campaign
database or i mean i could give you a
talk to an hour on that subject alone
and then what could happen is we might
knock on the neighbor's door and just
let them know there's a property for
sale on this street introduce us as
agents now god by the way my son might
be interested in that and then the son
comes along and buys it but then on the
other hand we could do a tick tock walk
through tour like we sold a seven
million pound luxury apartment it was on
for three years
with very well known corporate luxury
estate agents we sold it in three weeks
and the top buyer of the 32 that come
through the door
the daughter saw it through tick-tock
and the dad who's canadian
bought the property
authorizing it effectively through a
tick tock lead so what i'm saying is
yeah it's crazy now that was a that was
a hundred thousand pound fee
off of it a hundred grand from a
tick-tock video effectively
you could say yeah nice so why do your
videos get so many more views though you
mentioned about other estate agents and
i have i've seen them do little videos
do you know like the traditional types
of and they'd often tank yeah but you
all seem to go viral yeah what is it how
does that happen the thing for me is i'm
i have a bit like yourself you know i
can see with everything you do in your
business you have extremely high
standards you know and for me my
standards with everything in business
and the way we market properties is
extremely high if our estate agents or i
don't like call them estate agents five
real estate agents um do a property
video tour and it's dull it's lackluster
it's uninspiring then i'll pull them up
on it we give them guides on how we have
specific videographers we work with who
have
editing rights to make it engaging to
make it effectively explode onto
people's um social media yes platforms
so that way
because what i explain to owners
is when you launch a property people
think you're looking you're you're
marketing to a buyer you're not at that
point because you don't know who's
buying the property
what you're competing for and the
currency at that time is attention
that's all it is it's attention so
you've got the difference between
someone seeing your property
scrolling past it or bang it explodes on
there and they go i might just watch
this for a little bit longer oh my god
this looks really good oh let me speak
to my dad about buying or let me come
and view it myself or whatever it might
be and then suddenly the engagement's
there and then it converts to a viewing
and then a potential offer now that
happens on right move that happens on
instagram that happens on linkedin the
same principles occur if there's [ __ ]
photos or no video tour it's not
engaging or it hasn't been marketed
properly
then people are just going to scroll
past it so we need that engagement there
in the first 10 seconds 20 seconds yeah
and then we get them so do you think
you're dominating in the real estate
market because you understand marketing
that's the main thing
i think um
[Music]
the funny thing is is that marketing is
one thing if you've got 30 brilliant
buyers through the door of a property
but the agent who's receiving those
leads is absolutely rubbish then and
he's not trained to the highest level
yeah then that becomes a redundant
process in itself because suddenly
you're giving you're effectively letting
someone let all this money slip through
their fingertips offers slip through
their fingertips because they don't know
how to handle them they don't know how
to negotiate they don't know how to get
the price up to the what the owner wants
or
the alternative is they haven't done
their job properly at the market
appraisal stage so we spend a lot of
time training our agents not only to
just tell an owner what they want to
hear if the property's worth three
million
and the owner wants four
then there's a problem yeah so you know
our our agent doesn't go there and say
yes sir no sir three bags full sir they
show us we showed pound per square foot
evidence market data sold property
similar properties of square foot all
that sort of stuff probably the research
you have to do with your research is
that the same process
fail to prepare prepare to fail it's the
same with any business if you don't
prepare for that meeting and get
everything ironed out to the owner not
just says i think it's worth the other
estate agent said it's worth all of that
nonsense absolute rubbish they just say
whatever you want to hear yes they do
and then and then they get the listing
and then they then slowly over weeks and
months bring it down and down chip away
here and you're in contract with them
yeah it is unethical
it is unethical and actually what they
end up doing is underselling people's
homes um and
what happens is
if you don't have that correct
conversation with an owner firstly that
owner is being misled because they're
being misled by an agent who's told them
the house is worth too much money
secondly you might actually
deliver
the perfect offer for their home
but if they're
deluded into thinking that it's worth
20 more than it actually is
they think you've failed yeah when the
reality is you haven't you've delivered
correctly but they've not they haven't
been educated enough or shown by an
expert yeah what their properties are i
think the thing i like about you guys is
the fact that you are unique
you kind of you go you don't you don't
go
with the with the grain and you go
against the grain against the status quo
and you do what you think is right and i
think that's why you're winning
marketing is aggressive but different
your the whole way you structure it it's
just completely different how have you
been received by other agents
uh i think we're not going to be getting
any christmas cards from any estate
agents um but i i kind of prefer it that
way um the reality is is that um i've
my views on estate agency are very clear
for all to see i believe that the
industry is absolutely in the in the
stone ages and when you go to countries
like america to australia you know these
are marketing wizards these are people
who are
marketing these luxury properties on
every single social media platform
they're engaging their audiences they're
on television shows they're you know
they're driving supercars they've got
faces on billboards
what are our estate agents doing having
a [ __ ] outside the office
before they get let home to go at six
o'clock because they haven't made 150
phone calls before lunch
come on it's apples and oranges isn't it
you know you know i used to be an estate
agent same i used to be an agent and i
kind of went my way
and you you know you can't imagine you
conforming to that very long dude i
lasted three months bro yeah
i lasted three months i thought they had
a shock when you turned up
you know how did you get your tv show
with channel four um i knew that was
coming and i knew it was coming before
it ever happened and the reason being
was when i watched shows like million
dollar listings selling sunset and how
inspiring and how um kind of innovative
these shows and these individuals were
all i did was i thought right i'm going
to try and make i'm going to make us
more innovative and more marketable than
even them which i still actually believe
we are i don't
have any problem in saying that
and
that meant that when it come calling
that shut the television channels were
looking for the british version and
they've tried it a couple of times but
let's have it right i mean you watch
some of these shows i'm not going to
name names but
when they've got estate agents showing
20 million pound houses and you know you
fall asleep in the first five minutes
it's not inspiring with us we we had
nearly 30 different production companies
call me um basically saying we you know
there's been a release they want the
british kind of selling sunset million
dollar listing and we had a few
production companies battling it out for
us and then we finally agreed on one got
the show um to pilot got it through to
them
and then they uh
yeah and it aired on channel four um
mega mansion hunters um it was a good
show i think it was um
it was filmed like nine ten months ago
nine ten months before it went out yeah
so it was a little bit like watching a
bloody you know it was a bit old you
know we've evolved a lot since then um
from your perspective it was old
it was great because my biggest goal
with the business was to make us a
household name now we are so are you
hoping for a season two didn't there'll
be one i think one way or another will
there will be um i believe it needs it
as i said there's been a large evolution
across the business with regards to the
agents the properties we're selling the
levels of property the way we market
ourselves the reach the money everything
we've got agents in our business
picking up supercars you know it's it's
we're setting the trend for for where
estate agency and real estate is going
in the uk and you know that for me
should be aired and it should be shown
on television what are you driving these
days
a lamborghini yeah nice so
you're making good money from this
business yeah
right what do you think people watching
this if they wanted to get involved i
know a lot of i personally know people
that have become agents within tyron ash
what's the process like and how many
agents do you have working for you yeah
so i think the the agents across the
business is just shy of a hundred um
obviously some are in kind of early
training stages um others are more
experienced are they full-time or um so
it's it does work around schedules for
people so when you think about kind of
um you know we we need people to be
treating it like their first
vocation their first full-time um
responsibility yeah but
you know with any kind of thing uh when
it comes to kind of running your own
business these are self-employed agents
so they're on the same set up like the
american and real estate with american
and australian real estate brokerages so
it's a 50 commission split um so there's
no basic salary so there's no no prizes
for for for taking part um but there's a
lot of commission at stake you know
average sale
we're talking what one 1.5 million
average fees probably 30 grand 25k
they're only 12 to 15 grand per sale
yeah and there's many agents earning 20
30 40 grand a month um it's you know
it's a good income so not only are you
making good money but you've been able
to help your agents that's the driver
you look why why is that the driver
because i i'm a i'm an agent i mean i
could go and make 200 grand a year 300
grand a year plus just selling houses
myself
what i love is teaching it i love i love
showing people how they can do it
and that's what my main
role has become
you know i'm not a manager i'm not a you
know i'm i'm not somebody who people
report to what i am is i'm showing
people the methods
of how to list successfully how to get
properties sold how to market them to
the widest possible audience how to get
multiple buyers through the door and
drive the price up to the best possible
price for the owners and how to get the
thing over the line to exchange your
contracts and do you invest in property
yourself i've bought a few buy to let's
years ago it is something that um i've
got it's on my to-do list this year yeah
that's good somewhere to do this this
year um what's the plan with tyron ash
where do you see it going in the next
five years it's a great question um i
think the next one is dubai um i'm gonna
be launching dubai
probably going to be the start of next
year
and i think realistically i want to
saturate i want this business to
saturate the uk i think that the
dinosaurs have been around for a long
time in the luxury end of the market
are vulnerable
and no one really has the balls to go
and take them on
the the bottom line for me is every real
estate brokerage every self-employed
agency that's set up they naturally like
with any business they they float to the
bottom
because it's safer it's a lot safer for
them we're not interested in that we
want the top end of the market and we
are going to stop at nothing until we've
taken it because i imagine it's not much
it's the same as as a property investor
as a property developer a big deal in a
small it'll take very similar effort but
one will get you'll get 10 times more
money and i imagine it's very similar
yeah no but if you're selling a house
that's 100 house it's probably going to
take just as much effort to sell a
million pound house it just takes more
effort and i'll tell you why because
what we find in the sales process is
that unfortunately the solicitors that
they use on a two three hundred grand
sale are always cheap bargain solicitors
yeah right you know you've got a central
email and a central switchboard phone
number can't get hold of anyone someone
who's not qualified is checking down a
list to say whether they've checked it
off before it's ready for exchange yeah
no common knowledge no no nothing no
initiative you know with um someone
who's paying five or ten thousand pounds
for solicitors fees
they've got an expert on it that expert
messages us on whatsapp and tells us
what's going on and
uses their their knowledge to get the
property through in the quickest time
possible for their client yeah so it
doesn't sit there for six months it sits
there for six weeks same when you're
doing development because there's more
money there's more profit in the deal
you can pay better qualified people to
help you with it yeah what's um
i know you've had a little bit of
criticism
over the last few months not even a few
months but and and for me i i said to
you this privately it's like it's normal
when you blow up and when you're
conquering
you can't have people not coming for you
you're gonna have the media you know and
that's the thing when you first start
out people say oh it's a silly idea
whatever they'll laugh at you then you
get a bit of success then they'll start
hating you and then when you become a
household name which is what you're
becoming now and you prove yourself and
you've got credibility then people just
go okay fair enough and respect you so
you've you know you've obviously had
some criticism
how do you especially when
you're like me say my company is called
samuel leeds limited and the reason i do
that is because i'm putting my name on
it yeah if i can't put my name on it if
i'm having it as some faceless company
then really i shouldn't be running that
company i need to prepare to put my name
on it um but when you've got a company
that you put your name on it and it's
your heart and your soul your customers
and you and you've got people the media
writing stories and coming after you
how do you how do you personally and as
a business how do you deal with that
it's a brilliant question because um
weirdly it started it was um i'm very
much somewhere i don't like someone
telling me i can't do something um it's
not it's not in my dna it's not in my
vocabulary um so
when i was at one of these real estate
companies a self-employed brokerage an
american firm won't give them the
benefit of naming them but um
i wanted to basically have my name as
the real estate name um but because i've
got a bit of a colorful pass that's
probably you can sort of dig around and
find out um
you know they were like we don't want
your name on the boards associated with
this real estate brokerage so can you
just call it like you know whatever
property or whatever and i was like no
i'm putting my name on the on on the on
the business that's my name if people
don't like it then no problem
so that was really the main driver so
when we launched this then my name is
going smack bang in the middle of those
[ __ ] boards like that's it and you
know and and because i know what i'm
doing i know i'm not an idiot i know how
to list and sell luxury homes and i know
how to build a brokerage
of experts that know how to do exactly
the same and my name will be on that
board and that's how we did it so like
you know that was always a thing i
thought i would never be told i can't do
something but then what's happened is as
the tv shows come out the exposure has
been brilliant um which was what we
wanted but then i've had god um the
daily mail
i have got a personal vendetta against
me i mean they just i've been called a
narcissist i've been called
god everything under the service man
your business no well that's it and i
think if you're delivering and you're
good at your business no i mean it
doesn't the thing for me is these things
don't affect me words don't hurt me you
know my you know give me something
serious to worry about and i'll you know
deal with it not you know someone write
a newspaper article because they don't
like me um unfortunately i don't lose
any sleep and they don't know yet no
they don't exactly they just see they
just the thing is people just see your
marketing front your personal same with
me and then they just come to
conclusions they haven't even sat down
and had dinner with you they haven't yet
yeah yeah is it did it hurt business did
it help business no it helped massively
help matters all controversy is good
right yeah controversy yeah yeah exactly
and i think that like the thing for me
was that um
i've never made it a secret that i had a
criminal record i've never made it a
secret about my past i've never made
anything a secret nothing was a surprise
so when they start putting these things
in the newspapers in headlines and all
these things i just think well i have
just talked about it on a national
television show so you've not discovered
anything yeah um you know i've kind of
took the sting out of that a little bit
and uh and it's
it's more of a story of someone who's
gone through they're acting like aren't
they great journalists they've found
this information out that you spoke
about on nationals yeah they're national
television i was stood outside
i was still out i didn't even see you
know what i didn't even see any of the
bad stories about you because i don't
even look at it yeah i only know about
it because you told me yeah i don't even
read the newspapers i'm not interested
and funny enough i don't i don't i don't
um
i don't either because um i think
they're never writing about anything
good are they
bad news sells more headlines
journalists and and media have really
really they're selling out because
people are reading it less and less
because of social media yes so they're
trying to be more and more sensational
actually you're trying to grab people's
attention yeah and and it's just you
know it's strawberry yeah because you
have to sue them if it's not true though
yeah i think that i think the
the thing for me was that like it just
doesn't affect me the way they want it
to affect me so i don't really care what
they write i don't really care it
doesn't affect me all i care about is
you know that the business is going
where it needs to go the people in the
business have the utmost support from me
to be able to do their job to a really
high level and you know we have very
very happy clients who refer us and use
us and you know that's what it's all
about um you know for me it's a
newspaper article here and there it's
what's more important to your business
marketing or sales
uh
that's a bit of a chicken on the egg
chicken in the egg question because
i feel like um
if you can't market yourself correctly
and attract the business then you won't
get the sales
are you good at sales
i'm exceptional oh yeah yeah very good
absolutely so what is sales what does it
mean about taking someone through a
journey where they can
learn about whatever it is you're trying
to sell so whether it's a product or a
service they're learning about it and
you're delivering that
in the most beneficial way possible for
them so they can actually see the
physical benefit of engaging with that
service or product
and then it's taking that from point a
to point b
and then believing
or understanding not believing because
not untrue but actually understanding
that by engaging that product level or
service that you have delivered
that enriches or makes their life or
current circumstance better yeah that's
what selling is yeah it's good and not
everyone can do that do you know what a
lot of sales people why a lot of sales
people are bad i think because they
don't qualify the person they're about
to sell to they don't listen so for me
sales the first thing about sales is
actually understanding what they want
and if your product or service is not
right for them then telling them this is
not right for you absolutely if it is
right for them then it's about making it
easy for them to make a decision and go
ahead
and a lot of people get people think
they don't like sales oh i hate sales
i'm not salesmen because they've they've
seen someone sell bad yeah and they've
been annoying right they're not the door
and trying to sell them double glazing
or something i'm not interested i've
already got double glazing
and the sales person's being pushy and
not but if you're a good salesperson
you'll ask questions you'll listen and
if you've got something that they need
and they want then you'll make it easy
to bring the two together 100 100 and i
think um the funny thing is with
certainly associating associating it
with with real estate i believe it's
definitely not a hit and run sell so
yeah a large portion of that is the
rapport building and delivery afterwards
absolutely yeah if you can't deliver
then you know what are you there for
and i think that over time the big the
pendulum kind of swings and at first
it's very like outbound out where i'm
out burned door knocking lead generation
follow-up follow-up follow-up follow-up
but what happens is through this process
you get people who trust you they use
you they use you again they refer you
they use you they see your boards going
up they see your social media posts your
credibility goes through the roof and
guess what happens
you become an attraction agent and
everyone comes to you and then it's very
easy to sell because you're just
picking up the phone and there's money
at the end what's the most expensive
house you sold
uh in the business nine million um
personally myself i did a sale at twenty
two and a half million uh oh wow yeah
would you that okay but that wasn't part
of toronto that was before yeah dude man
we gotta get stuck okay
so um an average sale is about what
average average sale price is our
average sale price a lot it this this
side of this year was just under two
million brilliant so you're going for a
lot of high end yeah and this time last
year was just under 900 grand
so there's a really great spikes our
sales pipeline is is six times what it
was last year yeah
what's the most
the biggest misconception about real
estate agents
uh i actually think the misconceptions
people have in the uk are not wrong
estate agents are a joke and for me
um you know the the industry needs
shaking up to a different level um real
estate agents actually i find if you go
to like america go to australia i
mentioned earlier
they're viewed like
lawyers doctors
they're professionals you know so
they're not paid 20 grand no they're
they're they're the richest guy on the
street yeah richest person on the street
and and the funny thing is is that it's
because they are experts at marketing
your house they're experts at
negotiating your sale it is a profession
and we just think it's we've treated
them like the second-hand car salesman
oh yeah just stick him in the office on
the high street hand out a few leaflets
yeah clock in at nine o'clock out at six
what's the biggest difference between
tyrone ash and most estate agents uh
most estate agents well i can tell you
the easy way to describe it is britain
has designed a state agency
in a way where the timeline doesn't
change you list the property you market
it you take your viewings or an open
house you negotiate the sale you
exchange contracts that's the timeline a
real estate agent is someone who becomes
an expert at every single part of that
process so the minute you meet them at
the listing and then they market your
property through social media they
negotiate yourself for an impressive
open house process they take the
property up to its maximum level to get
you the best possible price they chase
your property through to exchange of
contracts handing over the keys to the
new buyers um you watch an expert take
that whole process through so you're
ryan sirhans you josh altman's all these
amazing real estate agents that we love
and admire on television they're experts
at that whole timeline yeah with estate
agents what they do is they take that
timeline and they divide it up into
little jobs so what they do is they say
right we're going to instruct a valuer
to go out and just value he's going to
he or she is going relationship build at
that precise moment it becomes a hit and
run sell
oh yeah our company's great we're gonna
do this we're gonna market this sign
here here here batman band contracts
back into the office on to the next
market appraisal that's our value it
works then that listing goes back to the
office the administrator types it up
goes out to these sales negotiators
who've probably never seen the house
before on the phone do you want to view
it do you want to view it do you want to
view it do you want to view it that's
all they do they're like battery hens no
offense but they are and then what
they'll do is they'll get paid a little
bit of commission when they sell the
property 25 quid that's how much i used
to get
it's true
my basic guess what my basic was
i don't know if it was lower than what i
had go on what was yours mine was eight
and a half grand
one was 11. oh you left that many money
bags yeah
and so what they they've done is they've
kind of divided this whole process into
me remember little jobs and then what
that means is they give you a three
percent there five percent commission
there five percent commission there and
the reality is is they net 90 of the
deal
as the the corporate brand or the estate
agency and they pay everyone off
real really low kind of money and really
low wages and you know that is why there
is a fundamental difference and i don't
even like it when people call us estate
agents because we're not i don't put
myself in the same categories and i
don't put our agents the same category
as them we're real estate experts that
know the whole process from start to
finish
and become that trusted person to handle
the process
not
a sales negotiator who works on the high
street and goes home at six yeah big
difference what do you want to be
remembered for then um
i i would say um
i i want to change the entire industry
like for me this is this has got
political
um this is something where um
it started off as i wanted to build a
big business then you realize the hatred
and the pushback you get from these
estate agents and other people in kind
of these corporate environments and you
realize the reason there's so much
hatred and pushback
is because you get you're exposing them
we're delivering on properties that
they've had for two three years and
we're getting them sold
and in a process that's far beyond what
they do so for me that shows me i'm on
to something
so for me it's about being the person
that changed uk estate agency into into
effectively real estate it's a good goal
my brother
and i work with a lot of estate agents
so for me it's good to see and i'm not
saying i don't necessarily agree that
they're all useless i think there's some
good ones there are there are i think
it's the structure yeah it lets them
down it's not them yeah yeah structure i
get it it's great to catch up what made
you agree to come down
i've always been a massive fan of you
sam i think um your approach to business
and the way you're helping people build
businesses and build their careers in
property development is inspiring and i
think that for me if um and i know it
will be something i do but there'll be
one person i'll be coming to on property
development and that'll be you and i'd
recommend anyone else to do the same big
up respect man thanks for coming down
pleasure i think